[Music]
my most esteemed guests you're about to
enter the world of backstabbing and
treachering so trust no one except me of
course
I've been training for this since I was
five I'm direct I'm honest to a fault I
mean I would have picked that outfit so
I don't think I trust your judgment
completely whatever
you're like literally a cancer to the
group yeah oh really what about the
Traders taking your money and killing
you at night I've tried to talk to Kate
numerous times and she won't talk to me
I don't trust anyone oh yeah you're next
you're next door I don't care come at me
I will but I will that's fine you want
some honesty Rachel you look like you
get dressed at a community theater
you're literally the only person who
thinks it's cool they were the first Big
Brother baby no one cares
no one cares
any player can be put on trial okay so
don't we can't rule them out as only
faithfuls correct I am so loyal I don't
want you guys to waste the banish on me
and so yes honey I'm looking for every
excuse to get you gone yesterday was uh
I mean I was a train wreck I had I was
freaking out you must feel so bad and
you sent her home she was trying to send
me home no she wasn't she wasn't because
I don't think we should just like go
after one person and if I can save
myself by throwing her under the bus or
get ready because I'm gonna throw her
under it play in reverse and run back
over top of her because I mean I'll do
it if it means saving myself
Rachel is alive this is like my chance
to use their fandom of me to my
advantage and sometimes it's annoying I
don't want to toot my own horn but the
only issue is my ears hurt I'm kind of
an icon I can't wait to murder her I
could totally nail this by myself I
actually found
so called your honeymoon oh
I think I ever
pretty ballsy that he thinks I'm gonna
buy what he just told me because I know
for a fact Ryan's I could throw my name
out
one of the last things Ryan said before
the round table I'm suspicious of
Kyle Ari and Rachel I think that the
only person here capable of manipulating
deceiving lying stabbing is someone
who's done it before not once twice and
what you told me was that hey
two people that I know Ryan has never
suspected
so you're telling me yeah straight up
yeah Ryan said those three names those
three names straight to my face
Cody really what the hell are you doing
think about how exhausting it is to like
live a lie
yeah yeah I mean or if you were dating
like 20 women at the same time yeah and
they're not on you okay
[Applause]
keep it together he needs to remain calm
some people are not doing good nuts you
guys he's a very high maintenance it's
very loud you guys hurry please please
listen we speak positive brother hush
shut up like shut up razor baby I don't
know how I can convince you just like
Geraldine couldn't convince y'all just
like poor Michael couldn't convince you
I don't know what I can do to convince
you maybe the question is why do you
think I'm a traitor give me a reason why
you think I'm a Trader so I can then
disprove that
I stayed true to my own vote and I
always gave my own reasoning I threw
names out when nobody else would so I
didn't vote with nobody not even the
group
yo Kate's throwing the money away okay
because I'm a liability Christian is
kind of like a bulldog I have something
to tell you all now oh Jesus after the
last round table I was recruited to be a
Trader
what I don't know what he might say I I
just I feel like it could be apparently
as faithful as we have to try to get one
we got to nail one on the first round
table I'm so glad you're here
now I don't know ditto gosh so
Savage that is so Savage
who wants a glass of wine
still gorgeous